Denny Hamlin won his third Daytona and
he joins us on the program
Denny congratulations take me through
the last two laps of yesterday yeah just
uh for me is kind of crazy but we were
you know obviously leading coming with
two to go and then we uh I'm trying my
best to stay in front of those guys but
I knew that you know I had seven boards
I think lined up behind us and you were
the only two at that point I knew that
they were to be coming with run so also
turn to I he told me that the guys were
to my both Ryan's were two lengths back
and I knew at that point I was probably
too far ahead so I kind of relinquished
the spot I didn't want to try to grow a
block and end up getting us crashed on
the backstretch so those guys got beside
me and they got past me and I linked up
on the back bumper of the Blaney and
I made my best shot was to kind of push
him towards the lead and just kind of
see what happens and and those guys head
down hit you know came off turn four
went towards the yellow line you know I
knew that there was going to be contact
so I tried to stay as far right as I
could away from them but I saw a Ryan
Newman's car turn right right in front
of me and as soon as that happened I saw
playing his car and I went down inside
drafted him and got that lunge right the
start/finish line just just enough to
win it all again felt like he had to go
to to third to get back to first yeah I
mean I thought that you know I had an
opportunity to stay next to Ryan down
the backstretch but Blaney but I knew
that if we were going to be side by side
and then the race was over for me so my
best option really was to kind of push
him back towards the lead and then
hopefully either they get together or I
can go three wide at the start/finish
line so I knew my best opportunity I
wanted to check up and to turn three get
to Blaney's back bumper and push him
towards them and when did you realize
you'd want
Yeah right when I cross the line I mean
I've been in a photo finish there in
2016 which is the closest finish in
history and I think this was now the
second so I've been in that position
before and I knew that I was I was just
far enough ahead to the beat him but
it's crazy because you know it's just a
you know 100 or 200 yards before the
start/finish line we were you know about
third place and we just somehow I made
it up up there and won the race and you
know it's very unexpected especially
after that you know going down the
backstretch and I laugh when I go back
to third I just thought that the race is
over but we just kept digging
when did you realize something was up
serious no serious nature with Ryan
Newman yeah I mean I didn't know
anything until I got in victory lane
not until you know that when they called
off the interview at the start/finish
line they I knew that something was up
at that point so I drove in to victory
lane and they said you know you know
there's a serious injury with Ryan I
hadn't seen it yet so I saw the camera
person there and they had the monitor
and they were replaying it and I and I
watched her back then I was like wow
it's just definitely serious and so it
was you know a bit of a quiet victory
lane I guess you could say you know
there wasn't you know because there was
a lot of speculation a lot of you know
not questions that people didn't know
and but luckily we got some better news
later on that evening but I thought that
your owner Joe Gibbs and you both
handled it I mean you guys knew that
there was something serious even when
you got out of the car you're basically
saying hey you know what we won I'm
happy but you know I don't know what
just happened to this driver and even
with you know Joe Gibbs saying basically
the same thing like it was a muted
celebration by your team yeah I mean I
mean it has to be right I mean it is you
think about you know someone's
well-being or someone's health is
obviously way more important than you
know any sporting event you could you
could win you know we're out there for
entertainment purposes right I mean you
know
got two two daughters and I've got two
daughters myself and so you definitely
can relate and and you definitely think
about you know them and their family
during that time and you know just from
my perspective and we still haven't
celebrated you know it's still this is
going to take you know time to kind of
think about and reflect on in the next
few weeks I don't think people
understand the magnitude of that track
though Danny because the feeling I got
reading some social media is how are you
celebrating with a wreck you're probably
a mile and a half away from where Ryan
Newman's car is I guess give people
perspective of where Victory Lane is
with where Ryan's car was yeah and even
the surface time they were all towards
camp between start/finish line and turn
one and you know I'll be honest with you
there's there's wrecks at the end of
these races nearly every single time so
there's this is definitely not out of
the ordinary but simply when when we
went to the start/finish line and they
the Peavey personality came up and said
that no interview here I thought
something was up and then when we went
to Victory Lane and NASCAR official came
and talked to grew up with that's when I
made it like hey actually told the guys
like stopped don't throw any more
Gatorade you know that he's seriously
hurt and everyone at that point just
kind of settled down so you know it's
just it's so far away and like I said
this track is two and a half miles in
length so yeah you can be what you would
think is close proximity and here you're
a mile away if I would have told you ten
years ago you'd have three Daytona 500s
what would you have said what am I going
to start winning it's I mean it's crazy
I'm to have the rough we've been on in
the last five years to win three of them
has been incredible and we've just you
know definitely feel like I've gotten
better at those types of races they are
different than what we run on a weekly
basis but it was just kind of
and a knack for it and it's things if
the results have showed all the work
that we put into it so one of several
different ways like I said you know part
of the two closest finishes in history
but I tell you it it's an amazing run
that went on right now you know what's
strange though when I'm watching this in
real time and I I see the crack we're so
used to you guys just getting out of a
car I think member yeah click Boyer with
what happened to him and then he cars on
fire he puts his glad to take gets out
takes his gloves off and a couple of
years ago and just throws him in the car
like we're just so used to you guys
being indestructible with these cars
with the tracks with the walls here and
I think that was what was shocking you
just kept going late he's not getting
out he's got to get out and then then
the serious nature really set in yeah
absolutely and I mean it it's it's
something that sometimes we do take for
granted because you know cars and all
the equipment that we that we wear has
the innovations and the safety
advancements have come so far but when
you forget that and we are going 200
miles an hour and in time a car can turn
up on its roof like that that's an
opportunity for another car drive right
into it that's kind of what happened so
it was definitely a worse scenario you
know that's probably the the weakest
part of the car the most exposed is
right there through the roof or through
the you know Jarvis car wininet but you
know luckily we got you know like I say
that you know much better encouraging
news that we think it's gonna be okay
well congrats Denny I know that that
will get lost in it and obviously Ryan's
health is paramount here but I thought
you and coach Gibbs and your team
handled it extremely well well I
appreciate it man Thank You Denny yep
thanks Dan for more game Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]